with the no more tables technique below
a certain viewpoint with the table is
collapsed and resembles a long list as
opposed to table data the nice thing
about this technique is all of the data
is visible no matter what the size of
the viewport is let's take a look with
the baseball score again in a wider
viewport everything looks good but as
the viewport shrinks the table collapses
every column has essentially become its
own row with the table header beside it
using a media query I need to tell the
table that below a certain width in this
case 500 pixels I don't want it to act
like a table anymore inside my media
query I'm going to force all table T
head t body th TR and TD elements to
render as display block next I need to
get rid of the table header I could set
display none but that will cause
accessibility problems for people using
screen readers because the browser won't
tell them the column headers instead I'm
just going to position the content way
off screen since the table cells are now
displayed as full width block elements I
need to add some left padding and also
set the position on these elements to
relative to add the row labels I'm going
to use the before pseudo selector and
add TD before and inside I'll set the
position to left colon 6 pixels so that
I get it positioned in the right place
now I need to add the content I could
put the labels in my CSS but that's a
key and will mean that these Styles will
only work for this table instead I'll
use content
attr data th that will then pull the
values from the data th of each of the
TD elements here let me show you and
there you have it that data th is used
as the label for each of the rows